hello
this morning I met with Commission's
coronavirus response team we discussed
about the situation in Italy and what
additional support we can provide I also
spoke on the phone with Prime Minister
Culture and expressed my support for the
Italian people we agreed to have a
videoconference meeting within the next
days to discuss in detail about how we
can support more and what further
measures would help Italy was also part
of our discussion and will be part of
our videoconference on the whole of
Europe I asked the coronavirus response
team this morning to look into further
tools that the Commission can mobilize
in order to address the overall impact
the corona virus outbreak has on the
economy throughout Europe many sectors
are already suffering and we will need
to look for ways to support them for
instance and this is just one example
aviation the corona virus outbreak has a
major impact on the European and
international aviation industry we see
that the situation is deteriorating on a
daily basis and traffic is expected to
decline further and this is why the
Commission will put forward very rapidly
legislation regarding the so called
Airport slots we want to make it easier
for airlines to keep their airports slot
even if they do not operate flights in
those slots because of the declining
traffic this is a temporary measure and
this temporary measure helps both our
industry but it also helps our
environment it will relieve the pressure
on the aviation industry and in
particular on smaller airline company
but it will also decrease emissions by
avoiding the so called ghost flies when
airlines fly almost empty planes simply
to keep their slot again this is just
one example of a sector where help is
needed and we are ready to act this
morning we also discussed more broadly
with commissioners about what we can do
with the member states to reduce the
effects of corona for example to contain
the spread of the virus coordinate
responsive measures accelerate research
accelerate research on treatment on
diagnosis for example on vaccines and of
course we discussed about the impact on
the economy I encourage my commissioners
to get involved with their stakeholders
this morning commissionable atone had a
video conference with manufacturers of
protective equipment and within the next
days he and Commissioner kiriakidis will
talk with the pharmaceutical companies
that are in question concerning the
corona virus outbreak it is important to
get discuss about the state of supply
and what the state of play is at the
moment being so you see we're simply
looking into all tools that we can
mobilize to address the impact of corona
virus on people but also on the economy
last but not least I will inform the
heads of state and government at the
video conference this afternoon about
the tools we can activate in this corona
out like after different stages thank
you so much
you